Tim Ferriss: Hello, my friends and frenemies.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of The Tim Ferriss Show, where it
is my job to deconstruct world-class performers,
to tease out the habits, routines, tools,
favorite books, etc. that you can use and
test and apply to your own life.
The topics we explore the experts we interview
range from people in the military to entertainment,
sports, and everything in between.
This is an everything-in-between episode.
My guest is Jason Nemer, co-founder of AcroYoga.
You can find him on Instagram @jasonnemer,
N-E-M-E-R.
My apologies for the sucking in the background.
That’s my dog obliterating a Kong.
This is audio vérité, for you folks.
Jason is an incredible character.
He’s a vagabond.
He travels the world with next to nothing
and has introduced me to my obsession for
the last 6 to 12 months.
Now, along with gymnastic strength training,
I’ve been doing AcroYoga.
I think about doing it all the time.
It is not what you think in your mind of as
yoga.
It is totally different because I, of course,
have found yoga, historically for me, very
boring and I always strain a hamstring.
It’s not fun.
This is the opposite of all of those things.
It is closer to partner acrobatics, a Cirque
du Soleil routine meets sensual, but not sexual,
contact.
If that makes any sense.
If it doesn’t, it will in this episode.
There are lots of takeaways, lots of recommendations.
It was also videotaped.
We do a couple of demos.
You do not need the video, because we walk
through it in audio.
So you can definitely just listen to this
podcast.
But if you want to see some of the demos visually,
you can go to Youtube.com/timferriss to see
it.
It was filmed at CreativeLive, my favorite
place to learn online.
Creativelive.com.
Go to creativelive.com/success – I asked
them of all of their courses, they have hundreds,
I’ve done a lot with them – what would
they recommend that I share with you guys
and they brought up Six Months to Success,
which is actually Six Months to Six Figures
by Peter Voogd.
So Six Months to Six Figures by Peter Voogd,
V-O-O-G-D.
It has incredible reviews.
Just check out creativelive.com/success.
But I want to keep this as short as possible.
It’s already long because I had a lot of
caffeine and I’ve done a lot of thinking
on AcroYoga today.
When I’m not doing it, I want to be doing
it.
By the end of this episode, you will know
why and hopefully you will get a chance to
try it yourself.
So please enjoy.
Jason, welcome to the show.
Jason Nemer: Thank you.
Tim Ferriss: What are we drinking, here?
Jason Nemer: What a great way to start.
Tim Ferriss: I enjoyed the label so much I
have to share it with the world.
Jason Nemer: It’s Duck Shit Oolong Tea.
Tim Ferriss: Duck Shit Oolong Tea.
Jason Nemer: It’s true.
Tim Ferriss: What is the story behind the
Duck Shit portion of that?
Jason Nemer: Back in the day, I hear, in a
region in China there was this amazing tea
and it was so good that they had to play it
down so they called it Duck Shit tea, and
it was played down for however many centuries
until it’s been discovered as an excellent
tea.
Tim Ferriss: It’s not bad.
I’ve got to say I’m enjoying the Duck
Shit fragrance oolong tea.
It is almost as odd sounding as our first
encounter.
I remember the dinner at which we met, and
this was in LA, probably Venice, maybe Santa
Monica.
Jason Nemer: Santa Monica.
Tim Ferriss: It was at whose home?
Was it Andrew’s?
Jason Nemer: Dean’s home.
Tim Ferriss: Dean.
I was with my buddy Travis Brewer.
Jason Nemer: The ninja.
Tim Ferriss: The ninja.
Who is very much worth checking out for those
people who have not seen him in action; American
Ninja Warrior and so on.
We were sitting somewhere close to each other,
maybe next to each other.
Jason Nemer: We’d captured a bunch of photographs
of the day, just running around doing craziness.
Tim Ferriss: That’s right.
At the Santa Monica Green and elsewhere.
Of course, you are the co-founder of AcroYoga,
but I didn’t have much in terms of exposure
to AcroYoga.
So I said, “What is AcroYoga?”
You said, “I’ll show you.”
That led to an Instagram photo that I posted,
which was something along the lines of “Just
another Saturday night, not sure how I ended
up here.”
And I was in reverse bat position.
Jason Nemer: Well done.
You know exactly the pose.
Tim Ferriss: In what I used to call butter
kinase.
Jason Nemer: Baddha konasana.
Tim Ferriss: Baddha konasana.
I’m not good with the such-and-such onasana
– memorization of terms.
What is that?
How would you describe what that looks like?
Maybe we’ll do a quick demo on what that
looks like.
Jason Nemer: Basically if you were a human
bat and you were hanging upside down and you
were holding your ankles, that’s pretty
much what it looks like.
Tim Ferriss: It’s kind of a Spiderman position.
Jason Nemer: Yeah, Spiderman, upside down
monkey business.
Tim Ferriss: Upside down with your feet together
sort of in a butterfly position.
Jason Nemer: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: And then the person who’s supporting
you, you the base, are on your back, legs
roughly straight up in the air in an L-base
position.
And your feet would be basically right on
top of my upper thighs.
Jason Nemer: Correct.
Tim Ferriss: Those are the shelves.
I remember being spun around.
I felt like I was in a washing machine of
sorts, which is actually a term of course
you use in Acro.
It just blew my mind.
What are the origins of AcroYoga?
How did it come to be?
Jason Nemer: Any time we talk about origins,
there’s my version of my experience of the
story.
There’s the historical perspective.
So what I’ll do is I’ll share from my
perspective what and how this all came together.
Basically, I had a lot of acrobatic experience.
I started when I was 12 and I competed in
sports acrobatics, which is basically like
gymnastics and figure skating put together.
It’s a routine with partners, music, dance.
So I competed in that for many years.
I found yoga in college and then ended up
in San Francisco, where I met Jenny, the co-founder.
Jenny had a background in the therapeutic
flying so what you were describing, being
upside down and being massaged, that’s something
that I learned from Jenny; she learned it
from other people.
So AcroYoga to me was me and Jenny meeting
and pretty much putting together our bag of
tricks.
Tim Ferriss: That bag of tricks, I will say
just in terms of personal experience, has
been incredible because you have not just
the acrobatic – and this is a term that
maybe you would not use, I don’t know, but
very kind of yang-driven strength, athleticism
component which is the acrobatics.
But then you have the very yin, very restorative
therapeutic Thai massage.
There’s more to it, of course.
But my hips, after now doing this reasonably
consistently, particularly the last two months
but for the last however long since we met.
Jason Nemer: A year, year-plus, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, a year-plus.
Good lord.
I realized today that I’ve been a professional
writer for ten years, almost to the dot.
Jason Nemer: Wow.
Well done.
Tim Ferriss: I was like, man that explains
the hair loss.
It’s been a long fucking time.
But my hips, my knee issues, ankle flexibility,
my progress from grumpy baby position, for
those of you who know yoga at all.
Imagine you’re lying on your back kind of
holding onto your big toes and pulling your
knees into your armpits.
Historically very uncomfortable for me; still
not my favorite place to be but much improved.
And I feel years younger.
Athletically speaking, more mobile than I
was even when I was competing in wrestling
and in jiu-jitsu judo and whatnot.
What was the birth moment of AcroYoga, per
se?
When did that meeting turn into Acro, which
is now practiced in how many countries, would
you say?
Jason Nemer: I went up and counted recently.
We have 55 countries that there are certified
teachers, but it doesn’t mean that the reach
isn’t bigger than that.
But it’s definitely a global practice at
this point.
The creation story is actually pretty magical.
Jenny and I had been hearing about each other
and we were training at the same circus center.
She was doing contortion during the day; I
was teaching trampoline at night.
So we kept orbiting around each other and
had a lot of common friends but just didn’t
meet.
When we finally met, we got together at a
party and I immediately put her into a hand-to-hand
where she’s doing a handstand on my hands.
Then she put me in folded leaf, which is you
would say the down dog of therapeutic flying.
It’s where my body is in a hanging, surrendered
position.
My head’s in her belly and she’s supporting
my weight.
That was the first time as an acrobat that
I felt what it was like to be inverted but
not be engaged.
Because acrobats are very controlling and
controlled in their body.
But to surrender, it was amazing, just those
two poses.
Then we were up until 5:00 a.m. talking about
this practice that would use all these different
skill sets.
We saw how things like partner yoga would
help people communicate and with the basic
therapeutic flying that’s not very advanced,
teaches people acrobatics in a soft way.
We put really all the pieces together that
night.
Tim Ferriss: It was orbiting, orbiting, orbiting
and then –
Jason Nemer: Collision.
Tim Ferriss: Collision and synthesis.
Let’s rewind just for a second, to go back
to the – and I want to get the term right
– the acrobatics.
What was it?
Jason Nemer: Sports acrobatics.
Tim Ferriss: Sports acrobatics, which I believe
is also what Andrei Bondarenko uses.
Jason Nemer: Yes, he was a sports acrobat.
Tim Ferriss: From Cirque du Soleil, who I
spent a bit of time with in Los Angeles when
he was there, also did.
What are the categories?
Because you have what?
It’s like two men, two women?
And then mixed gender?
How does it work?
Jason Nemer: It’s the pairs; you have three
different pairs.
Men’s pair, women’s pair, mixed pair.
You have women’s trio, and you have men’s
four.
That’s the partner acrobatics.
And parts of sports acrobatics is also platform
tumbling.
This is when you have a 100-foot long strip
and people run full speed and do crazy flipping
and twisting.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
I saw, I think it was a quadruple back flip
from Russia.
Jason Nemer: It was on my feed.
Did you see it?
Tim Ferriss: I think it was probably from
your feed or Coach Sommer’s feed.
Jason Nemer: I’d never seen a quad tumbled;
I’d never even imagined it was possible.
He did it easily.
It was nuts.
Tim Ferriss: It was insane.
So the men’s four, let’s talk about that
because I think this is something people may
have seen in performances in Vegas or elsewhere,
very often by people from Eastern Europe or
former Soviet Union.
What does that involve?
Jason Nemer: Men’s four, you usually have
two bases that are about the same height,
same build; a middle which I would be a good
size for a middle in a men’s four.
I’m 5’9”, 160.
And then the flyer, vary in sizes; always
the smallest one.
And basically if you know cheerleading basket
tosses, they do a lot of tempo skills, is
what it’s called, where the flyer does flips
and twists and lands back on the basket.
There are actually three different routines.
There’s a balance, a tempo and a combined.
Balanced routines in men’s four is just
a pyramid.
It’s no music, and it can be the base is
doing a back bend, for you yogis – Urdhva
Dhanurasana.
Then the three people are standing on this
guy’s belly, and the guy on the top is doing
a one-armed hand stand, cray-cray.
Tim Ferriss: That would have been Andrei?
He was a flyer.
Jason Nemer: Yeah, he was a flyer.
I don’t know if he did men’s four or men’s
pair; I don’t remember.
Tim Ferriss: I’m almost positive he did
men’s four.
He could correct us, of course.
Andrei Bondarenko.
You should check him out on Instagram.
Jason Nemer: Such a nice guy.
Tim Ferriss: Sweetheart of a guy, and just
a monster.
Jason Nemer: A badass.
Certified badass.
Tim Ferriss: For those people who, as I didn’t
know, basket case?
No, not basket case.
Jason Nemer: Basket toss.
Tim Ferriss: Basket toss.
Basket case is me.
Basket toss sounds like something pornographic,
and it might be.
But in this case it’s effectively –
Jason Nemer: Further down you hold your wrist.
Tim Ferriss: You hold your wrist and you’re
basically with other people weaving a –
Jason Nemer: Human trampoline.
Tim Ferriss: – human trampoline with your
forearms.
It just blew my mind when I first saw, at
Cirque du Soleil.
You were there when with Andrei we went behind
the scenes and we saw them warming up.
They’re just getting launched 20, 25 feet
and then landing on this human trampoline
that is effectively the size of the top of
a stool.
It’s just incredible.
And I remember Andrei and I were having tea
and he was talking about at some point – and
I’m going to paraphrase this, obviously,
and maybe butcher it.
In the Ukraine when he went to some type of
regional championship and there were a bunch
of people warming up, different teams.
One of the teams had a flyer who’s super
aggressive and wanted to make an impression
on everyone and tried something really outrageously
hard.
It was a concrete floor and he just took a
head-first spill on the concrete floor.
Those folks got carted out and the competition
continued.
That was his path, all of their paths, out
of that world and into one of prosperity and
economic feasibility for careers.
Jason Nemer: I heard a very similar story,
and this is something that I see as a potential
pitfall of acrobatics and potential pitfall.
I trained in Bulgaria when I was 15 with the
Bulgarian national team.
The year before we brought them to California
and took them to Disneyland – blew their
minds – and learned from them.
I heard a few years after that that the men’s
four, same thing; wanted to intimidate the
other men’s four.
So what I was describing are these four high
pyramids.
They were doing a four high, one-armed pyramid
and they fell and the kid broke most of his
bones.
He didn’t die but it was the end of his
career.
I think also for the 2008 Olympics in Beijing,
there were a number of Chinese gymnasts who
died trying vaults; trying to do these very
difficult vaults.
Yeah, the dark side of acrobatics can be when
your body is an obstacle to your goal, and
this is where the yoga and acrobatics can
weave so intelligently the dynamic power of
acrobatics but the reality that you’ve got
in your body for your whole life.
How do you make these educated steps towards
what you want?
Tim Ferriss: This comes back to the surrender
component, which may sound very woo-woo to
some people listening and that’s okay because
we’re in San Francisco, so suck it up and
take it.
Jason Nemer: Woo-woo!
Tim Ferriss: We’re not going to get too
crazy.
Maybe we will.
I’m flashing all over the place; I know
this is a bit like Memento.
But one of my other influences is this coach
named Jerzy Gregorek, who is the Polish Olympic
lifting coach I’ve mentioned a few times.
He’s 62.
Leaner, stronger, more mobile than I am by
many factors and he’s probably 135, 140.
He can get on an Indo Board, like a balance
board and hit a perfect snatch with a barbell
loaded full of weight, ass to the floor and
then stand up and put it back on the floor
with effectively no warm-up, like cold.
He’s just an extremely impressive athlete.
His longevity is phenomenal.
He said to me at one point – because my
habit, of course, is push, push, push, break.
Jason Nemer: You?
Push?
Tim Ferriss: I know.
Stop everything for a while because I’m
incapacitated.
Push, push, push, break.
And he said, “You have a Ferrari engine.”
I’m paraphrasing here.
But he said, “Remember, you have a Ferrari
engine in a Hyundai body.
Like you’re going to just blow yourself
apart, or it’s like your mind is willing
but your body is not adapted.”
So you need to – not his words, mine – chill
the fuck out and play the long game, which
I’m becoming better at.
Part of what has aided that is the therapeutics.
Something as simple as you mentioned surrender.
So in the type of training I’m focusing
on right now, I’m actually doing the GymnasticBodies
work with Coach Summer, he’s the former
national team coach for men’s in the U.S.
He was on the podcast, as well.
But that is not a surrender type of training,
and it can’t be to do it properly.
And I really, really enjoy it.
But if I’m doing that, say, two days of
stretching, two days of strength training
per week, I might then be doing – and I
have been doing – Acro on Mondays, Wednesdays
and Fridays for an hour to an hour and a half
in the mornings.
Just the traction alone that you’re able
to get, and for those people who are wondering
what the hell traction is, simply put – and
chiropractors may disagree with this – but
let’s just imagine you’re on an inversion
table and you get flipped to a point where
your head is below your feet and you feel
your spine is being decompressed; think of
that as one form of traction.
You can get traction on your wrists, traction
on your ankles.
I thought what might be fun, and this is going
to be a visual component; we’ll try to describe
it, but you mentioned a couple of things.
You mentioned folded leaf.
Would you say that is a good place for people
to start with Acro?
Jason Nemer: There are a lot of good places
to start.
Therapeutic flying, what I like about it is
it’s very soft and gentle.
If there’s extreme mobility issues, I think
there are other things people can do to gain
confidence and to learn how to communicate
what they need.
The way that we teach the practice is base/flyer/spotter.
So the spotter cannot only keep it safe but
they can also make sure that the base is in
the correct alignment.
So it’s too hard to say that this pose is
the exact place to start.
Tim Ferriss: But it’s one place to start.
Jason Nemer: It is a good place to start.
Tim Ferriss: Now, when you say base/flyer/spotter
– that is simply to say that generally you’re
practicing in groups of three?
Jason Nemer: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Let’s just show, and for those
people who are listening to audio, I’m sure
I mentioned it in the intro and I’ll probably
mention it at the outro.
If not, you can check in the show notes, fourhourworkweek.com/podcast,
but we’re capturing this on video.
So you might as well do some stuff that’s
well suited to video, and we’ll talk through
it.
Let’s go to this mat, here.
Jason Nemer: Oh, wait.
We’ve got to do it the right way.
Tim Ferriss: I was going to catch you!
Jason Nemer: My Dutch friends would kill me.
Tim Ferriss: Then I lean back, and then we
bring the partner down.
So apparently the Dutch acrobats get very
upset if you don’t do that.
And I’ve gotten to the point where I’m
like, you know what?
I’ve had enough of the Dutch.
I love their kickboxing, Ernesto Hoost, love
you.
But from all the jiu-jitsu I’m just like,
flop.
I’ve made a lot of – I’m not going to
say enemies; that doesn’t really happen
in Acro.
So I am standing with my feet reasonably close
to your hips.
Jason Nemer: I want to be able to touch my
flyer’s feet.
My feet are turned out just below the hip
bones.
Tim Ferriss: I am standing straight up.
It’s almost as if you’ve seen the UFC.
You’re like open guard on your back.
This would be where I try to punch you and
then you’d kick me in the face but that’s
not Acro, that’s MMA.
All right.
And then flyer, fingers forward.
Jason Nemer: You’ve got it.
You’ve got the acronyms and everything.
Tim Ferriss: I’m a young Paduan just learning
what I can.
Jason Nemer: The most important thing is that
you understand when to be water and when to
be earth, and what parts of your body.
So I’m going to be watery with my arms and
really sturdy with my legs.
So we’ll take a deep breath.
On the exhale, I receive with everything and
then I push up with the legs.
Here, a lot of times the flyer will want to
put the hands down and practice their handstand
training; that means they’re a control freak.
Tim Ferriss: So you fold the top of their
hands down to the floor.
So at this point, for those people listening,
I am supported on Jason’s feet.
I’m completely upside down.
I’m basically in an L-straddle position,
for those of you who know anything about gymnastics.
So this is folded leaf.
Sometimes in hush tones, jokingly referred
to as leaf blower.
Jason Nemer: Oh, my God.
I didn’t know that was going to come out
in the podcast.
Tim Ferriss: I’m trying to help people with
the images, here.
This is scarecrow, right?
Jason Nemer: This is scarecrow.
Basically what I do as a base is I try to
let your body unwind patterns.
So as I bounce and shake, a lot of times our
mind is connected to muscle groups and flexing
them when they don’t need to be.
So the true therapist is gravity, which helps
to let your spine hang like a plumb line.
Tim Ferriss: Could we show, for instance,
super yogi?
Jason Nemer: Sure.
Tim likes traction.
So what I can do is I can let my legs come
off my 90 degree.
His weight will start falling back.
We’ll take a deep breath together.
On the exhale, my legs go back and I resist
with the arms.
Okay?
Two more.
Inhale, exhale.
So I’m pushing the legs back then giving
resistance.
You’ve got a little wrist traction there.
One more time, inhale and exhale.
And then where I love to go is to open up
your triceps and your shoulders.
So I’m going to place my hands under his
elbows and he can bend the elbows and the
knees at the same rate.
Okay, bring the elbows closer.
Does that feel okay on your shoulder?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I’m going to be a little
careful on the left just because I had it
reconstructed but yeah, this feels fine.
Jason Nemer: And in general where the body
can be vulnerable in the flying is in the
shoulders and the lower back so communication
is really important, and just listening to
your body.
All good?
Tim Ferriss: All good.
Jason Nemer: Sweet.
Side bending is also a thing that can really
help the health of the lower back.
And what’s different with the therapeutic
flying from yoga is your body doesn’t have
to be engaged.
You’re not using your muscles as the flyer
so you don’t have to work uphill, basically.
Yeah, mon.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, mon.
So those are some basics of therapeutic flying.
Some people who heard a bunch of grunting
and weird noises and just don’t know what
the hell is happening, or from people who
might have seen the video.
Actually, let’s demonstrate one more thing.
Because I was in South America doing an immersive,
which was a great experience, meaning a two-week
intensive of AcroYoga training.
The first week was dedicated to the acrobatics,
second week to the therapeutic flying and
Thai massage.
I was visiting a friend of mine named Chris
who has developed some lower back and hip
issues from a lot of sitting.
He’s a former high-level athlete.
I gave him what is sometimes referred to in
the Acro community as leg love, which is typically
done – for those of you who just saw it
or I’ll just describe it.
So Jason is on his back basing me, supporting
all of my weight on his legs, in effect.
That can get tiring.
And so after you’ve received effectively
massage, being floated on someone’s feet,
you then help to –
Jason Nemer: Release the tension.
Tim Ferriss: – release the tension in their
legs and restore their legs a bit.
Jason Nemer: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: And so I did that.
Actually, I’ll demonstrate.
Jason Nemer: All right.
Bring it.
This podcast is getting better and better.
Tim Ferriss: So what I did for Chris, and
this is something I’ve done for a number
of people, now.
And obviously, consult your qualified AcroYoga
professional.
I’m no doctor; don’t play one on the internet.
But let’s say we just came down.
So boom, we came down and we’re here.
There are a couple of very easy things you
can do.
So just from this squat position, I’ll get
his legs straight.
Then I’ll actually just hold his feet in
between the crease of my leg and my upper
body and then lean backwards.
So I’m giving him traction at the hip and
the lower back, even though I’m not holding
onto anything.
Jason Nemer: It’s so good on my ankles,
too.
Tim Ferriss: And a lot of traction on the
ankles and external rotation.
Other things that are pretty easy to do would
include, you can do a little bit more traction.
So you step in, and I’m just going to shake
the legs to get them to relax a bit, and then
turn the feet in, put them behind my hips
and lean back.
Jason Nemer: What’s great about this pose
is therapeutic flying is an external rotation;
this is a counter pose, it’s an internal
rotation.
So that’s where some of the yoga intelligence
starts sneaking in, is how do you counter
the muscles you’ve been working?
Tim Ferriss: And for those people who are
say, like cross fitters who are afraid of
seeming too crunchy to their buddies or whatever
it might be, this is an excellent complement
to any type of Olympic lifting or lifting
that involves squatting.
I’ve found this to just be a huge performance
enhancer, to have this done.
Jason Nemer: Can you just get on my feet for
one second in a bird, just to show what my
theory is of why your hips are a lot more
evolved now?
Squatting flexibility.
Tim Ferriss: Look at this guy’s hips.
Jason Nemer: It gets increased when you have
170, 180 pounds on top of you.
So it doesn’t just warm the body but it
lets you access new flexibility.
Tim Ferriss: That’s one that you need to
watch the video for.
Yeah, if you want to see freakish hip mobility.
Jason Nemer: I have open hips; it’s true.
Tim Ferriss: Open hips, good birthing hips;
then you should watch the video.
I’ll just demonstrate a few more that are
super simple.
There are many, many options.
We could do bus driver; that’s what this
one is known as.
They all look really silly and they are as
profound, I think, for athletic performance
or just general health, as they are, in some
cases, ridiculous looking.
Another that I’ve found just incredibly
helpful is just swinging.
So this type of movement.
I won’t do too many more; you can get fancy
and do like the circle eights and stuff but
I’ll show one more and then we’ll get
back to the interview.
So in this position, and feel free to correct
me if I’m messing this up, but you can effectively
push down on the feet and get the hips off
the ground, and then use the hand – or not
– to loosen up this entire lower leg and
hip region.
Literally just doing those few things, I was
able to alleviate Chris’s lower back pain
significantly, symptoms 40 to 50 percent decreased.
Jason Nemer: Awesome.
Tim Ferriss: That is, in my experience, not
just a Band-Aid.
It’s not like you swallowed a bunch of ibuprofen.
With regular use, the effect seems to be very
persistent.
My hips feel great and it’s like I never
thought in my entire life I would ever say
that.
Jason Nemer: That makes me so happy.
That is the goal of the practice is that you
can find a way to interact with AcroYoga that
will affirm who you are now and who you’re
going to be for the rest of your life.
One of the really cool things that I’ve
seen is acrobats, yogis and healers, all three
lineages, people can do it until they’re
90, 100.
Gymnasts, not true.
I have not seen 100-year-old, high-level gymnasts,
just because it’s very high impact.
But there are styles of acrobatics, styles
of yoga and styles of healing that are really
affirming who you are so you’re not depleting
yourself as you’re learning these cool things.
Tim Ferriss: Coach Summers said, I think it
was, I know in the world of high level gymnastics,
I know a lot of stupid people and I know a
lot of old people.
I don’t know a lot of stupid, old people
who have made it that long.
But speaking of some older folks, you’ve
mentioned to me a number of your teachers,
a number of your influences.
Could you talk about Lu Yi and your experience
with your healing teacher, and just give some
context on who these people are.
Jason Nemer: Sure.
So Lu Yi is a Chinese acrobatic master; he’s
a circus master.
He traveled throughout the world back in the
‘50s.
He was actually telling me a story about when
he performed in Africa and they had this act
where you throw these big pots around and
the pots land on your head.
And the Africans carry things on their heads
so they weren’t impressed; they didn’t
clap and they had to take it out.
So he’s just a treasure trove of really
amazing stories about the circus.
He’s been in the Bay Area for quite some
time now.
I met him about 13 years ago.
I’ll give a little short story about this.
I met him, I go into the circus center.
I compete at high-level acrobatics but I hadn’t
trained high level in a while.
I see him training people with one-armed handstands.
And I as a base never learned how to do a
one-armed handstand on the ground by myself.
So I’m like, “Mr. Lu Yi, you look like
such an amazing teacher.
I’d be so honored to work with you.
I just did a yoga teacher training.”
And yoga is a four-letter word.
I might as well have just spit in his face.
So literally for the next three years, every
day I would see him in the circus center.
“Mr. Lu Yi, I’d love to work with you.”
“Oh, you have too much experience.
Oh, you very old.
My way different way.”
When I speak with my pretend Chinese accent,
it’s in so much love.
Tim Ferriss: It’s still pretty good, having
spent a lot of time in China.
Jason Nemer: Oh, my God.
So this is Lu Yi, and Lu Yi has been a mentor
in a lot of ways.
He has a lot of different techniques.
He’s right when he says that because he
came from circus and I came from sports acrobatics.
One day I go into the circus center and he’s
teaching a kid how to ride on a bicycle backwards
by sitting on the handlebars.
He knows so many random things.
And recently, just this year, he has sciatica
and he got into a car accident and it got
worse, and he’s basically been out of commission
now for quite a while.
I’ve been trying to connect him with one
of my other master teachers, who is Scott
Blossom, who is an amazing Chinese medicine
doctor, acupuncture, Ayurveda, which is an
Indian science of medicine, and he’s also
a shadow yoga teacher.
And in the world I think there are 20 certified
shadow yoga instructors; that’s a whole
other conversation but he’s basically a
triple threat, amazing human.
Today before this interview, I went to Lu
Yi’s house.
I picked him up, I took him over to Scott’s
office.
Lu Yi doesn’t speak English very well, and
I understand him and we have a good rapport,
so it was really good to be there.
And for about six to eight minutes, he was
just reading his pulses, just feeling his
hands.
From there, he basically did needles, did
a lot of different techniques.
Before he got him on the table, I was in a
moment where I just sat on the floor while
they were doing the pulses.
I closed my eyes and I did a mettā practice.
Mettā means loving kindness and this comes
from Thai massage.
Thai massage is an amazing practice that weaves
spirituality and healing.
So as I close my eyes and I’m meditating,
my heart is pumping, my hands are getting
hot; I’m basically cultivating all this
qi.
And I didn’t think I was going to be able
to lay hands on Lu Yi at all, but then when
he got him on the table, he’s like, “Jason
feel here.
Okay, put an elbow there.”
So I have two of my masters here and I got
to give love, basically, to this man who with
his hands has sculpted my handstand, my one-arm
handstand.
So it was just a really cool thing to feel
how acrobatics is really powerful but nothing
is more important than your health until you
start losing your health.
And to have these tools to help people feel
better, there are very few things in life
that I think are more noble to dedicate to
than learning new things to help people.
And mettā, loving kindness, compassion, meditation;
these are things that are very easy for everyone
on the planet to start practicing as soon
as they build the desire.
And I think human nature is such that we have
the desire that we want to help people, we
want to make people feel better.
So yeah, that was an amazing way to start
my day, to see these two masters come together.
Tim Ferriss: I’ve been very struck by a
few things just related to what you just said.
The first is that a lot of people who come
into healing have a history of being injured
themselves, or even injuring other people.
A lot of Judoka in Japan end up then going
into bone setting or traditional, let’s
just call it not traditional, but Western
medicine.
The second piece is that I was very surprised
when I did the immersive.
I hadn’t had any real in-depth exposure
to the therapeutic flying.
That having been so aggressive in all of my
individual sports to date, I’ve always,
since I was introduced to Acro, been obsessed
with the more dynamic, violent perhaps –
Jason Nemer: The shiny objects.
Squirrel!
Tim Ferriss: The shiny objects.
Yeah, which are – yeah, that’s the story
of my life.
But I was astonished to find that when I did
the immersive, I was actually in many ways
more drawn to the therapeutics.
I think that’s because I’ve just over
developed or over focused on the hard driving
aspect to such an extent that I don’t have
a rate limiter.
It’s like on my tachometer, I don’t have
any red zone.
I don’t even see it; it just blows apart.
That helps me to start to calibrate and pay
more attention.
By paying attention to someone else’s body,
I feel like you learn to pay attention and
listen to your own body.
Jason Nemer: For sure, especially if you have
good guidance.
That is a very strong principle from a lot
of my teachers; body comfortable.
If you’re not comfortable as a giver of
healing arts, you’re violating the first
thing.
So you actually get to be – and unfortunately
in English there’s not a good term for this
– selfish.
To be a good healer, you have to be very selfish.
You have to really listen to who you are,
to where you are and from that place if you
really understand, you have the potential
to give in a way that’s not depleting, give
in a way that’s not going to hurt you because
that’s going to be a very short healing
career.
Tim Ferriss: What is the handstand approach
that you thought of this morning?
So you mentioned this, and I said save it
for the podcast; I don’t want to hear about
it.
So tell us.
A lot of people listening are interested in
handstands.
There are a lot of crappy handstands out there.
Jason Nemer: I’ve seen most of them in different
shapes and forms.
This is where, again, I feel like the acrobatics
and the yoga start to mix.
I’ve been doing shadow yoga for about six
years, now.
There are three preludes [inaudible] –
Tim Ferriss: Does Ra’s al Ghul – he’s
the bad guy in Batman – he doesn’t run
shadow yoga.
It sounds like something out of like an Avengers
movie.
Jason Nemer: Marvel comics?
Kind of.
Zhander Remete is a Hungarian martial artist
who came up with this.
Tim Ferriss: Sounds like Ra’s al Ghul.
Jason Nemer: There’s some darkness to it.
Tim Ferriss: We’ll come back to that.
Okay, so we’ll dig into shadow but please
continue.
Jason Nemer: It came from my shadow practice
this morning.
So there’s a pose, and I’ll just do it
real quick.
There’s a sequence in one of the poses is
with the fingers are laced.
So it’s done like this.
Tim Ferriss: You’re standing feet shoulder
width apart, roughly.
Hands flat on the floor with your fingers
interlaced.
Jason Nemer: Yes, and I would never think
to do a handstand like this.
I was doing my practice this morning and I’m
like, huh, I wonder how hard that would be?
It was really fucking hard.
So 30 years of acrobatic training, I’ve
never seen anybody do that handstand.
I’m sure it’s been done and I tagged a
few people on Instagram this morning.
Andrei is one of them; Miguel_Hand_Balance
was another.
And my third attempt, I figured a couple of
things out.
Basically, if you let the pinky go wider and
you let the thumb go wider, you have a big
enough base and you’ve got to start using
the pinky and the thumb.
But it was just as much as I feel like acrobatics
is very fixed, gymnastics is very fixed, as
long as the mind is not fixed and if you have
the playfulness and you have a ritual of discovery,
this practice keeps expanding.
Tim Ferriss: I love the cross-pollination
when you expose yourself to different physical
disciplines.
So you have yoga, we have acrobatics, and
then you have what’s called sports acrobatics,
circus, Olympic gymnastics for simplicity’s
sake.
Jason Nemer: Artistic for the people who really
know.
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
So very interrelated but different disciplines;
break-dancing.
So for instance, that position you had right
here reminds me of, I believe it’s called
the 2000 in break dancing.
Jason Nemer: Check you out.
Tim Ferriss: So while you have a 1990, which
is a one-armed spinning handstand, which is
generally on this portion of the palm.
It is, mechanically speaking, very similar
to a pirouette even the way they go into it
with their legs and then bring their legs
together.
But a 2000, if you found somebody who is very
good at teaching or performing a 2000 and
explaining it, they would probably have a
lot to add to that conversation.
Jason Nemer: There you go.
Tim Ferriss: So if any B boys out there, B
girls, want to add some commentary on how
to do 2000s properly, you will assist me in,
at some point, having too much to drink and
injuring myself.
So that is that.
I have to just ask, what on earth is shadow
yoga?
Can you describe this, please?
Jason Nemer: Sure.
I love describing this because it’s something
in my recent past, I’d say five years; it’s
the thing that’s affected my life the most
positively.
As a gymnast and acrobat, I would have lower
back pain.
It would come and go, but it was a constant
teacher.
As soon as I found the shadow practice, for
over five years I wouldn’t say I’ve been
back pain-free, but if I wake up and I have
back pain, I know if I do my practice and
I do a number of things that are conducive
to my health, I can clear it.
So shadow yoga is Zhander Remete is a martial
artist.
He was in the Army.
I’m not sure which Army.
He’s a certified badass.
He’s such a deep yoga practitioner.
I’ve actually never met him but Scott, my
teacher, has told me a lot of things.
One of the things he did in a demo is he took
a deep breath, and then he sat.
Then he took another deep breath and he sat.
Then he looks with a big smile and is like,
“Do you know what I did?
I ate the breath.”
And he starts laughing.
Basically, he can just metabolize a breath.
He doesn’t need to exhale.
He’s a yoga master, full blown.
What he did is he studied in Pune from Iyengar.
Tim Ferriss: What is Pune, is that a place?
Jason Nemer: Pune is a place.
Pune is a place in India where Iyengar, who
is a man, who basically, other than Krishnamacharya,
the father of modern yoga, I would say Iyengar
is one of the most influential people who
has come to the practice of yoga.
So he studied with Iyengar for a number of
years, and he also went to the South to study
Ayurvedic medicine.
And in Kerala they have temple dancers, bar
nok diem temple dancing and they also have
Kalari martial artists.
And the martial artists and the temple dancers
were moving much more in circles.
He was watching them and he was learning Ayurvedic
science and be basically started to fuse all
of these things.
So if I were to give a couple sentences, an
elevator speech of what shadow yoga is, it’s
based in Iyengar technique for the asanas
and it’s got a Tai Chi feel and there’s
definitely a lot of circular movements.
So you start with warming up all the joints
of the body and he said – paraphrased – that
the martial artists and the temple dancers
for one year just did joint mobilization.
If you understand how to move all of your
joints very intelligently, then the more complicated
moves ride on the back of that intelligence.
So one of the things that makes shadow yoga
unique, as far as I’ve experienced yoga,
they say if you squeeze the muscle, you block
the prana.
So if you’re engaging your muscle, you’re
not letting the energy flow.
So what you do is you try to have your muscles
as soft as possible and you really put your
attention into the bone layer.
And you stack your body in ways that the bones
are taken away, the muscles are soft, and
you start circulating the energy through the
body.
Tim Ferriss: The bone stacking is a pretty
good segue into all sorts of topics.
For people who want to learn more about shadow
yoga, is there a particular resources other
than Google that you would suggest?
Jason Nemer: Yeah, shadowyoga.com, I believe.
They have a DVD.
The unfortunate reality is I think there are
like 20 certified teachers in the world so
he’s very, very strict on certification.
I mean talk about Mr. Miyagi, this guy is
the definition of yoga Mr. Miyagi.
Tim Ferriss: Salty old dog.
I like those.
I aspire to be a salty old dog myself so I
like hanging out with the cantankerous, opinionated
but highly competent salty old dogs.
Jason Nemer: He’s the guy for you.
Tim Ferriss: Although yeah, he might not put
up with me.
That’s a separate issue altogether.
Bone stacking.
Let’s talk about handstands for a second
again, and I always mess this up, is it ATB?
Jason Nemer: ATB.
Tim Ferriss: Look at me!
Jason Nemer: You also learned it in Spanish.
That was AIB.
Tim Ferriss: AIB, that’s right.
That was a whole thing in and of itself.
I did my entire immersion in South America
in Spanish.
There were a number of people translating
for a handful of folks who only spoke English
but I found it more entertaining to see how
badly I could mangle things by running on
the Spanish alone.
So let’s talking about ATB.
Should we do a little demo of what that means?
Jason Nemer: Sure.
Maybe I’ll talk a little bit, first; I’ll
paint an analogy.
I like the analogy of bridges.
Tim Ferriss: So ATB stands for what?
Jason Nemer: Alignment, tightness and balance.
I like it in that order because until the
body gets aligned in the most efficient way
possible, you are losing energy for every
second you’re attempting the handstand.
So alignment is the Holy Grail of all acrobatics.
What’s great about these ideas, the ideas
are really simple; the practice is a pain
in the ass.
It takes sometimes decades to get a straight
handstand.
But alignment is straight, straight is strong.
Our bodies are not made straight.
Our cells are circular, our bones are not
two by fours.
So it’s an impossible task that we try to
do to turn our bodies into these knives that
cut through gravity.
Tim Ferriss: What are some of the things that
Lu Yi says, his short expressions while people
are doing handstands?
Jason Nemer: Today one of his legs is not
working very well; he can’t walk up the
stairs very well.
And I joked at him.
I said, “Lu Yi, your body is not one piece.”
Because he says, “Make body one piece.”
Tim Ferriss: One piece, one piece.
Jason Nemer: Yeah, he likes the body to be
unified.
And then I have a Russian coach who says,
“Make body one bone.”
Same, same.
It’s basically unifying the body and that’s
the second part of the ATB; it’s tightness.
It’s integration.
Tim Ferriss: And if you see, for instance
– I know you’ve seen this, but for people
listening or watching, if you see a photograph
of a gymnast mid-air, or a diver for that
matter, they’re not relaxed.
Look at how tight they are.
Jason Nemer: And a cool experiment for those
of you at home who are interested, is you
can hard boil an egg and take a raw egg.
Try to spin them both.
I don’t want to spoil it.
Tim Ferriss: You can try that.
That’s also if you’re an idiot like me
and you hard boil some and you forget which
ones are raw, spin it and you’ll see very
quickly which ones are hard boiled because
they’ll fly off the counter, probably.
Jason Nemer: Another good Lu Yi-ism, and this
is good for anyone to put in their back pocket
and I’m so happy that Coach Summers also
agrees with me on this: MO extension.
M-O extension.
MO extension.
And what he’s talking about there, it comes
back to Newtonian physics: action and reaction,
the second law of motion.
If you push into something, it pushes back.
So as you push down into the floor, there’s
basically a rebound and this rebound is what
makes your handstand light and it’s what
makes the body a lot more unified.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
Also, if we’re going to look at the hierarchy,
if you were to do one – and I’m not saying
you have to choose one – but if someone
could not somehow wrap their head around the
alignment piece, if they didn’t have somebody
to help them but I just said you know what,
forget that.
More extension.
No, I’m just going to say it helped me with
my alignment to focus on the extension because
it took effectively one piece out of the puzzle
because it locked it in place.
But of course having someone to help with
the alignment is a huge resource.
But you were talking about bridges.
Jason Nemer: Yes.
So a bridge basically can be the analogy of
the body.
The metal is the bone structure.
So the first thing they do when they’re
building a bridge is they’ve got to get
the pylons in place and they have to get the
metal in the right alignment.
From there, they pour the cement, and the
cement is basically your muscles and the muscles,
just like the cement, can harden onto those
pieces of metal.
So basically you align the metal, you pour
the concrete.
As the concrete hardens, it gets super stable.
I haven’t really figured out the part of
the analogy of the balance.
Maybe it has something to do with the tension
of the cables.
Tim Ferriss: The cables or the fascia.
Jason Nemer: Yeah.
But at least the first two have a picture
for you to think about.
There was a point in gymnastics history in
the ‘70s where the Japanese gymnasts were
dominant, and they had a lot of techniques
that none of the other world had seen yet.
One of my friends was very connected to that
lineage and he said that at the Olympics,
they had a big interview with this guy, like
you have to tell us your secrets.
How are your gymnasts doing this?
They’re just blowing us all away.
He says it’s two things: strength and flexibility.
And that was pretty much the end of the conversation.
There was actually a third thing, in my experience;
it’s technique.
And one of my definitions of technique is
how skillfully you use your strength and your
flexibility.
So if somebody doesn’t have a lot of shoulder
mobility, if they’re doing handstands, they
want to get as much mobility as they can.
So Coach Summer calls it compression strength?
Tim Ferriss: In this particular case, he would
want – and it’s always dangerous speaking
for Coach Summer, one of my favorite salty
old dogs so he can slap me on the internet
if I get this wrong.
But if I had to guess, I would say that he
would argue that if you’re going to practice
handstands correctly, you would want to get
to the point where this type of shoulder flexion
is comfortable so that you’re not using
a lot of muscle to get here.
Jason Nemer: Yes, I would agree.
And whatever flexibility you have, you want
to access it.
So you want to eventually have a surplus of
shoulder flexibility.
I was born with circus shoulders.
So if you have a surplus of the shoulder flexibility,
being vertical is very easy.
That’s what you want.
But if you’re stiff, you don’t want to
not get that one-inch of flexibility utilized.
So basically the technique is using your strength
and flexibility as skillfully as you can with
what you have.
In one day, you can’t get stronger or more
flexible, but in one day you can affect your
approach and affect how skillful you’re
cutting through gravity with the line of your
body by finding these little hinges and taking
as much of those hinges out.
Tim Ferriss: What do you think about doing
a little demo?
Jason Nemer: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Alright.
Let’s look at ATB.
I’m thinking what might make sense, is I’ll
do I first.
Suffice it to say, I don’t think I have
great handstands but they’re trending in
the right direction.
Jason Nemer: I agree.
Tim Ferriss: They’re getting better, which
is all I care about.
I’m no Bondarenko, at this point.
Also weigh 100 pounds more; that’s not true.
I digress.
Alright.
Jason Nemer: So foundation.
You want to have your hands shoulder width
so you can put the hands down and I’ll just
inspect your foundation.
This is definitely where Lu Yi will spend
a lot of time.
Ideally, you’re tenting.
So this knuckle comes up.
And what that does is that puts a vector to
root the naughty knuckle.
Tim Ferriss: This is also very Spiderman-like.
If you ever see a close-up of Spiderman like
this on a cover, he’s tenting his fingers.
It’s hard to do without the ground.
But in other words, if your fingers are completely
flat on the ground, you’re popping up the
second knuckle while keeping the knuckle of
the palm on the ground.
Because if this pops up, what’s it called?
Jason Nemer: The naughty knuckle.
Tim Ferriss: The naughty knuckle, which is
this index that constantly pops up.
Jason Nemer: Your hands look great.
They’re the right distance apart.
You can go up however you’d like.
I’ll support you on the way up.
I’ll let you have your head neutral.
His head is down.
I step in between the hands, hug his thighs
and bring the ribs in.
Domesticate the wall.
Up, up, up.
Good.
Are you breathing?
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm, barely.
Jason Nemer: Elbows in more.
Good.
Looking down with your eyes, fall towards
your fingers a little bit.
Fall towards, right there, right there.
Yep, bingo.
Keep the hands strong, keep the breath.
Keep falling towards me.
Yes, right there.
Right there.
How you feeling?
Tim Ferriss: Good.
I think I’ll come down.
What I’d love to see, also, is if you could
go up in a handstand, and I’m not going
to do a great job of spotting; I’m working
on that, also.
But I’d love for you to show some examples
of common mistakes.
Jason Nemer: Yep, I love that.
I’m not going to do the most common mistake,
is taking my hands wider than shoulder width.
I want to have a vertical line so I’m not
going to compromise that.
Tim Ferriss: Do you personally point your
middle fingers forward?
Jason Nemer: I do.
Tim Ferriss: Some people – quite a few gymnasts
– do index but you prefer middle finger?
Jason Nemer: Well, and I don’t believe in
right and wrong until you define where you
want to go.
And what I teach is partner acrobatic handstands.
So if you’re practicing with the hands turned
out as a base, I’ll have to have my hands
turned in; super awkward.
So the techniques I’m teaching –
Tim Ferriss: Right, because we’re going
to be –
Jason Nemer: We’re going to be here.
Tim Ferriss: This is hand-to-hand grip?
Jason Nemer: It is.
Tim Ferriss: Reverse hand to hand.
Jason Nemer: You can practice with yourself.
You can’t practice hand to hand by yourself.
Tim Ferriss: Hand to hand is pretty tough.
Jason Nemer: Because you need a right hand
with a right hand, and not many people have
that.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Train as you want to; compete, so to speak.
Jason Nemer: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Instead of placing them too wide.
Jason Nemer: Okay, you ready?
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
So for those people wondering, that was a
straddle jump, basically.
Because from here, now if I were to just practice
my coaching here, so we have –
Jason Nemer: Before anything, I’d bring
the head down.
Tim Ferriss: Head down, okay.
Jason Nemer: Because then I have more access
to a straight line in my spine.
You can turn one of your feet to the side.
Yep.
Hug around my thighs with one of your arms.
Find my ribs with the other hand.
Now pull everything up and in.
Bingo.
That’s it.
Oops.
Technical difficulties.
Tim Ferriss: We’re good.
And then tightness would be I can pull your
feet apart.
Jason Nemer: You can also push me down.
Strong.
From the thighs, yeah, push me down.
Tim Ferriss: Push you down?
Jason Nemer: No, not that way.
Straight towards –
Tim Ferriss: Oh, down into the ground.
Got it.
Push you down.
Jason Nemer: Stronger.
Way stronger.
Tim Ferriss: Now I’m just going to do some
rotation stuff?
Jason Nemer: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Also doing this kind of stuff.
And then, let’s see.
Tightness, balance, and then we can do just
kind of a hot potato.
Jason Nemer: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Alright, so now you can either
come down or we can still demo.
What are some of the most common mistakes?
Jason Nemer: I’d say elbows are one of the
most –
Tim Ferriss: Bent?
Pointing the wrong way?
Jason Nemer: Both.
So saying a straight arm is a very non-descriptive
way to talk about how to position these bones.
So when you’re down here, basically you
can spin the eyes of your elbow forward towards
each other, or back.
What you want to find in a handstand is the
eyes of the elbows are squeezing towards each
other.
This gives you a lot of integrity in your
handstands.
So I’d say elbows from there.
Probably the head being really far away.
Tim Ferriss: Because that also just leads
to the cascade of piking at the shoulders
and then bending too much at the lumbar, trying
to use the legs to correct and then you’re
done.
Jason Nemer: So bring the arms up is another
good one, beginner acrobatics.
Relax.
Intermediate, advanced.
Expert is when the shoulders touch the ears.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I can’t get that high.
I’m getting better but not quite.
Jason Nemer: So if people get the shoulders
and the ears even close to each other, the
arms in a straight line, that’s going to
take care of a lot of the problems.
You really shouldn’t coach above the shoulders
for the first several months.
Tim Ferriss: Shouldn’t coach above the shoulders.
Jason Nemer: There are a lot of misalignments
from –
Tim Ferriss: You mean just coaching from basically
here to the fingertips?
Jason Nemer: Yeah.
From here down is where most of the big problems
come from.
So if you’re looking at why they are arching,
it probably has something to do with something
that’s happening from here down.
Tim Ferriss: You’ve said to me also there’s
a lot of magic in the hand and the foot placement.
Jason Nemer: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: So paying attention to that pays
dividends.
The next question I wanted to ask you was
– actually, one thing I wanted to just throw
out there that I found helpful, and this was
at a place called Athletic Playground in the
East Bay here in Northern California.
Jason Nemer: Serious place in Emeryville.
Tim Ferriss: That’s right, in Emeryville.
Great place.
I took a handstand class ages ago with a teacher,
Sam.
Jason Nemer: Sam.
Amazing teacher.
Tim Ferriss: Sam was amazing.
I remember what she had us do at one point,
and it was just such a simple idea.
And it was this: basically, she had us traversing
the room, going back and forth.
I’m not going to do it right now but I like
to walk.
She had us in rows and going back and forth.
We were supposed to go up into a handstand.
Now, it could be only 45 degrees.
If you’re a beginner – lest you topple
over, just go up 45 degrees.
And if I went up with this leg, I would come
down with this leg.
So it’s sort of like a scissor at the top.
And what she noticed is that people would
walk like this, and then they would put their
hands out, kind of like Frankenstein, and
then go into it.
She said all right, let’s try something
different, because people were flipping and
flopping everywhere.
She said I want you to do the same thing again,
but instead of that you’re going to start
with your arms way up over your head, shoulders
elevated.
This doesn’t move at all.
And I want you to do the exact, same thing.
And all of a sudden, just stability 10Xed.
It was incredible.
Jason Nemer: That’s basic tumbling.
That’s lunge, lever lunge is how I knew
it as.
It’s basically you make a straight line,
you bring a leg up and nothing hinges.
Your body just falls forward, you hit that
line and on the way out, as well.
So the ability to keep the body, again, in
one piece is what you’re looking for.
Tim Ferriss: One bone.
Jason Nemer: One bone.
Tim Ferriss: What other teachers or mentors
have had a big impact on you?
Jason Nemer: Dharma Mittra, yogically has
been an amazing teacher.
He’s a Brazilian yoga teacher.
He was born and raised in Brazil and he came
to New York and met his guru, Yoga Gupta,
in I want to say the mid-’70s?
Out of everyone that I’ve met in the yoga
world, he does the practice.
He’s super deep.
He teaches psychic development techniques.
Tim Ferriss: Psychic development techniques?
What are we talking about, here?
Jason Nemer: Yeah.
There are things that he learned from his
guru.
The practice is a lot of visualization and
breathing techniques, some humming sounds
that unlock vibration in the head.
Tim Ferriss: Which is a trippy thing to do
in a sensory deprivation tank, actually, which
I’ve experimented with a bit.
Jason Nemer: I bet, I bet.
Tim Ferriss: That is a full-blown psychedelic
auditory experience without psychedelics but
that’s maybe for a different podcast.
Jason Nemer: You know, vibration is vibration;
there’s a lot of ways to unlock those things.
Tim Ferriss: Hitachi magic wand?
Jason Nemer: Exactly.
You have one, too?
Tim Ferriss: Which, by the way, was recommend
to me by a Russian medical massage expert,
and not in the red light district, for relaxing
hypertonic forearms.
The original version, plug-in version, which
you can get at your friendly neighborhood
sex store, on high as it turns on.
I’m going to get my terms wrong, here.
Was that, not swami, guru, no.
Something Gupta.
Jason Nemer: Yoga Gupta.
Tim Ferriss: Yoga Gupta.
Are you referring to –
Jason Nemer: His guru.
Tim Ferriss: His guru.
Jason Nemer: Who’s an Indian guy.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Jason Nemer: It’s basically a lot of really
ancient knowledge that to some degree, a lot
of the yoga knowledge is able to be accessed
on the web.
You can really look.
Acrobatics still is not; it’s still really
hard to find any valuable acrobatic written
text.
The thing that’s valuable about yoga masters
is they communicate things energetically.
This is a saying that comes from Dharma Mittra
that came from his guru: “Once blessed is
a student that can copy the teacher physically;
twice blessed is a student that can copy them
physically and mentally.
Three times blessed is a student that can
copy them physically, mentally and spiritually.”
There was a day where the guru was gone and
somebody said, when is he coming back?
And Dharma started to move, as the guru does,
and started to speak with the same tone of
voice: “The guru will come back on May 31st.”
Are there 31 days in May?
Tim Ferriss: Let’s just pretend there are.
Jason Nemer: And sure enough, he came back.
So he’s a teacher of these very mystical
aspects of yoga and at the same time, he does
all kinds of crazy asanas.
Asanas are poses.
He has a poster of 908 yoga postures.
So when I saw this poster, I was like, I have
to meet this guy.
When I finally met him, the types of teachings
were much more fulfilling and deep than physical
poses.
It was really philosophies on life.
The way that he interacts with the world,
I just watch how he eats a salad.
He looks at every piece of food before he
puts it in his mouth, the mindfulness practice
and the compassion.
So yeah, Dharma Mittra.
Tim Ferriss: Big influence.
Jason Nemer: He’s 77, the same age as Lu
Yi.
The two of them haven’t met but I’ve got
my 77-year-old masters.
Tim Ferriss: Do you think they would love
each other or kill each other?
Jason Nemer: No, they would love each other
for sure.
And I’ve seen Lu Yi with a Thai massage
master.
I was really interested to see how that would
go.
It’s kind of like in Star Wars Return of
the Jedi when you’ve got the party at the
end, and you’ve got Anakin and Obi Wan and
basically all the dead Jedi masters hanging
out in spirit.
When I see masters together, I swear that’s
what it seems like because those magical spirits
are getting together and just celebrating
life together.
Tim Ferriss: Well, actually, before we get
back to the acrobatics, I want to ask you
about contemporary yoga, as it were; just
the state of yoga in the United States, popular
yoga.
I was put off by yoga for a very, very long
time.
And maybe this is going to be like speaking
out against the church.
I don’t know.
I don’t want to create any problems.
But I’m curious.
What are things that you see in the yoga world
that drive you crazy?
Aside from not pointing their feet when they
do handstands.
Jason Nemer: No, it’s job security for me.
The worse they do at handstands, the more
clients I’m going to get so I’m not upset
at their handstand techniques; that’s actually
great.
I feel just like religion, yoga can get very
one way; it’s my way or the highway.
This is the right way and everything else
is wrong.
That’s challenging to me about some yoga
systems and people.
I also feel that there’s a ceiling on yoga,
and the ceiling is you have all this amazing
knowledge, and all this amazing practice but
how are you bringing that into the world?
What happens when you’re in traffic?
How are you with your mom?
Do you talk to your mom?
Do you tell her the truth?
So I feel like AcroYoga and acrobatics and
other partner practices help to take that
wisdom that people spend so long cultivating
and they give it life; they give it access.
Tim Ferriss: That’s a good point.
You get to rehearse the human interaction
element.
It’s like, well that’s great that you’re
listening to a dharma talk and sitting on
the floor and doing your poses, and listening
to a speech about compassion.
But when you go to a restaurant and flip out
at your server because they didn’t get you
water in two minutes instead of their normal
five or whatever it might be, I never really
thought about that.
The community aspect and the communal practice
of Acro is one of the things that has kept
me with it, quite frankly because in many
worlds, there is a high degree of skepticism
or even aggression towards outsiders or visitors.
And you see this – not always – but in,
for instance, some – but not all – jiu-jitsu
schools.
An exception would be something like Marcelo
Garcia jiu-jitsu in New York where they’re
very welcoming but they have a zero tolerance
for bullshit or machismo or bullying.
to me that I have – and maybe this is just
delusional – a built-in group of friends.
And the fact that what it sounds like you
were alluding to is that the Acro helps you
to practice things that otherwise might be
compartmentalized to a bunch of poses by yourself
on a yoga mat.
I think that group practice or partner practice
also has led – and I don’t have any involvement
with the non-Acro yoga community but a lot
of the Acro folks, they do almost everything
together.
It’s not just the yoga.
It’s like they have group meals, they cook,
they do fundraisers, they help each other’s
companies.
That sort of tribal cohesion is something
that I think – and this was driven home
for me when I interviewed Sebastian Junger
on the podcast – is something that I think
we need as social creatures.
I could go on and on.
Jason Nemer: I’m so happy you’re going
on and on.
And for you, when I first met you, I felt
that I really hoped that you actually stepped
towards the Acro community because I feel
like people that are celebrity status, people
who are very good at what they do, it’s
really hard for a lot of those people to really
let their guard down and to feel accepted
as the human they are versus the titles that
they are.
So the fact that you’re reflecting this
means that what we’ve done to build this
community is working because everyone’s
a freak in so many ways.
What happens when you practice AcroYoga is
you still are practicing yoga; you still are
doing sola practices and you’re understanding
where your blockages are.
If you’re a big asshole, the community is
a self-regulating machine.
If there’s one person that keeps standing
out in the community, they’re going to get
told from many different people.
So we really hold a standard of evolution
and the way that we interact with each other
gives us the potential to keep evolving in
the direction that we want to as a community,
which is the counterculture to the iPhones,
to the Instagram, to the Facebook.
And I think those things are all amazing.
I think it’s really important that we learn
how to use technology in a way that leverages
more connection.
And I feel like there’s a big hunger for
real, authentic, wholesome human connection.
I feel like that’s what we offer.
Tim Ferriss: What do you think about doing
a little bit of, I guess you would call it
solar?
Jason Nemer: Acrobatic flying?
Tim Ferriss: Acrobatic flying?
Jason Nemer: Are you basing or flying, or
both?
Tim Ferriss: Either.
I’ll fly.
I’ve only been doing basing for the last
couple of months so this ought to be entertaining.
I’ll be the spry flyer.
But I don’t know what you think would be
of interest of folks.
I’m just going to demo something really
quick, don’t know which.
Primary?
So what I’d encourage people to think about,
just so we have some shared vocabulary here,
is think of bending at the hips as piking.
This is very over simplified.
Legs apart, straddle.
So this is going to be a very common position.
You can think of it just as like sitting down
on the floor with your legs spread and back
straight.
This gives you a 90-degree angle here.
This is shelving.
It is going to be used a lot in acrobatics.
Just so that I don’t have to explain that
when I’m upside down.
Jason Nemer: With that great description,
I think we should play with corkscrews.
Tim Ferriss: Corkscrews, okay.
Jason Nemer: Have you done corkscrews?
Tim Ferriss: I’ve based it; I don’t know
if I’ve flown it.
Jason Nemer: Today is your lucky day.
Tim Ferriss: Today’s my lucky day, okay.
Jason Nemer: Let’s go star.
Tim Ferriss: Star?
Yep.
So hand-to-hand grip.
I’m going to have these two fingers on the
wrists.
Jason Nemer: Basically I want to keep the
arms strong and the legs receptive, and you
can jump when you’re ready.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Jason Nemer: Let’s do up and down to straddle
that a few times, just to calibrate.
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Jason Nemer: I’m going to go to the other
side.
The other side is this one.
Alright.
Let’s go 180 to front plank.
Good.
That’s it.
Arms strong.
Switch the hands.
Switch again.
Straddle and go slow.
I’ve got you.
Look at you, twinkle toes.
Nice one!
Awesome.
Tim Ferriss: Thanks.
Jason Nemer: One more time?
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Jason Nemer: Good.
Arms strong, belly down.
Switch the hand.
Then second.
Straddle wide, nice and slow.
Nice.
We’ve got a bust to hand-to-hand; we’re
here.
Tim Ferriss: Hand to hand?
Jason Nemer: Yep.
Straighten your arms; don’t think about
it.
Strong arms, even stronger elbows.
Fall towards my feet, right there.
Mr. Tim Ferris, doing a hand to hand.
Elbows in more, arms in more.
Newton, push down, push down.
Yes.
Yeah, buddy.
Tim Ferriss: Whoa, that was good.
Jason Nemer: You even saved the day.
Right on.
Tim Ferriss: Alright.
Jason Nemer: You’re a flyer now!
Tim Ferriss: Thanks, man.
I’m trying.
Jason Nemer: It’s official.
Tim Ferriss: I’m trying.
I need to stop drinking gallons of cream every
day and take some weight off these thunder
thighs.
That was good.
Jason Nemer: Your fat is my fit.
Tim Ferriss: Your fat is my fit.
That’s true.
I was saying, I was actually working with
a flyer, very gifted flyer.
I don’t know if you’ve met Kiplinn?
Jason Nemer: No.
Tim Ferriss: Kiplinn Sagmiller, @Kiplinn on
all the social, K-I-P-L-I-N-N.
Very gifted.
I said to her at one point, “Kiplinn, you
realize that this routine is starting to get
easy; I need you to eat more.”
If this is going to be progressive resistance
for me, I need you to gain like ten pounds
a month for the next three to five months.
Jason Nemer: Maybe she should just get pregnant.
Tim Ferriss: That’s an expensive way to
train.
Jason Nemer: True.
Tim Ferriss: So a couple of questions for
you.
I want to talk about challenging times, just
getting out of some of the technical stuff.
And I apologize for having a very flat hand.
I was thinking about the hand.
I haven’t flown in awhile.
One of the things, actually, we might as well
explain this.
Do you want to explain it?
Jason Nemer: Sure.
Actually, let’s stand up for this one.
So the way that humans connect is the hardest
part in acrobatics.
We have more bones in our hands and feet than
the rest of our body so finding all these
micro angles is like wine; it gets better
with age and practice.
So if we have a straight arm line, if we go
really flat, what that means is like we’re
doing it on the ground and we feel a lot of
compression in the wrists.
If we go really steep, just like a steep angle,
we’ll feel it in the thumb girdle.
And we find that Goldilocks happy medium.
Little more flex; flatter, good.
And we lean into each other and really feel
not only our body as one piece but our collective
arm line as one piece.
That’s where the money’s at.
Tim Ferriss: You can calibrate that.
Do you want to do a quick calibration?
Jason Nemer: I’ll tuck sit on you?
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Jason Nemer: You’ve got to base.
You’ve got to earn your paycheck.
I going to not drop this.
Tim Ferriss: The mic right on my front teeth;
that’d be great.
Jason Nemer: So what’s great about this
is there’s not a lot of risk involved as
I just bring my feet up a little bit, testing
the water.
If that goes well, a little more advanced
would be a tuck.
If that goes well, you can baby hand to hand.
Arms more forward.
Forward, forward.
Yeah, keep coming.
Right there.
Better.
Awesome.
Your quality grip is nice.
Tim Ferriss: Nice.
Thanks, man.
It’s getting there.
So the testing here, and picking your feet
off the ground, and you can also do little
movements just to help activate the stabilizers
in the shoulder.
Jason Nemer: And what’s cool about the way
that we train with humans is there’s no
machine in a gym that can teach you how to
unify your body.
There’s no machine that can teach you how
to have a really strong line because it takes
human chaos to create the stability to match
that chaos.
Tim Ferriss: There’s a rig that I’m pretty
sure I came up with, but who knows.
Jason Nemer: Fairban rig?
Tim Ferriss: Well, actually, hold on a second.
Jason Nemer: That could work.
Tim Ferriss: The way that I put it together,
I was chatting with Coach Sommer, who helped
me set up this incredible rings contraption
that we were talking a little bit about, which
includes something called the 50/50.
You call it the dream machine.
Jason Nemer: Yes.
Thank God for the dream machine.
Tim Ferriss: It’s incredible.
So imagine you have a harness around your
waist.
It looks something like a rock climbing harness.
This one is from Sam, I think it is.
A lot of Sam in this episode.
You clip that to a cable that then goes up
over a pulley and then down to the rings.
That allows you to work with effectively half
of your body weight; let’s just call it.
Therefore you can progress in movements that
you might not be able to even attempt safely,
such as an iron cross, or a Maltese or a Victorian,
a Vic or any number of things; back lever,
etc.
But let’s just say that’s too intense.
Because right now, I have medial epicondylitis
in both elbows.
I also have severely inflamed right elbow
bursa.
This is olecranon bursa on the right side.
And putting aside all the weird drugs and
injections and so on that we might explore,
I’m going to put that as a footnote for
a future episode.
The device that Coach Sommer helped me to
install involves power levers.
So power levers – and I’ll put out some
photos and videos of this at this point for
people to check out – are awesome.
So now it’s in combination with the 50/50.
And you’ll see some people mimic this by
using straps, or they’ll fuss with the rings
in such a way that the rings are effectively
mid-forearm.
The power lever looks like a robo cop glove.
Jason Nemer: I already like it.
Tim Ferriss: It’s made out of metal.
There’s a strap that goes around the forearm.
On top of the forearm, you have basically
a uniform ridge of let’s just call it a
half inch that goes down to the top of the
hand.
Then perpendicularly, you have these holes
drilled – let’s just call it ten holes
– that go from the elbow to the fist.
Now, what does this allow you to do?
It allows you to take off the rings and then
clip in the ring strap at your elbow.
So now, the point of support is closer to
the fulcrum of the shoulder.
Jason Nemer: That’s even easier.
Tim Ferriss: It’s much, much easier.
But over time, you can then just move it out,
one notch at a time or two notches at a time.
That’s a little off topic related to the
handstands, but it’s just been an incredible
boon for training.
Especially if let’s just say you’re trying
to attempt a movement like a proper ring dip
with a support position at the top with your
hands really externally rotated.
Surprisingly hard to do.
There are people who can do 20, 30 dips who
cannot do two proper gymnastics ring dips.
So if you can only do two or three, you’re
doing a max effort set, effectively.
It makes it hard to get the skill practice
of that movement.
So you could use something like a 50/50 to
allow you to do maybe 10, 15 total reps; 20
in a workout.
The handstand rig that I was trying to figure
out came out of a problem.
And the problem was if I were kicking up to
a wall, or facing a wall, and then losing
my balance and coming out of it –
Jason Nemer: Even worse.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
My total time in the handstand position for
practicing the alignment, tightness and balance
was really minimal.
It was kind of like surfing, where it’s
like okay, I want to get good at surfing,
meaning standing on the board and carving.
But 99 percent of your time is spent paddling.
Jason Nemer: Swimming!
Tim Ferriss: Yes, swimming and paddling.
That’s fine; it’s part of the sport.
But what if you could use a wave pool or what
if you could use wake surfing?
Suddenly, you’re able to really accelerate
your progress in some very interesting ways.
We were chatting a little bit earlier.
I didn’t tell you about the rig but you
were like, does it involve just touching your
toes on something?
Which is what Coach Sommer calls a Chinese
handstand.
So you’re underneath a bar of some type
and you’re just touching with the tippy
tips of your toes, which requires you to maintain
a lot of extension.
The issue, though, that I would have with
that as a novice is that if I lose the extension
for a split second, I’m fucked.
Jason Nemer: You’re in trouble.
Tim Ferriss: I’m going to fall, one way
or the other.
Jason Nemer: Gravity is going to win.
Tim Ferriss: And then I have to get the hell
back up there, which is very, very nuanced.
So what I realized is I have a squat rack,
it’s a Rogue rack.
There’s a dip attachment that goes on the
side.
The dip attachment is literally about this
big.
What I’m doing, for those people who can’t
see me, my arms are bent 90 degrees, elbows
at the sides and my hands are straight out,
kind of like a Lego figure.
It’s roughly this big.
What I realized is the actual grips were big
enough for an Olympic weight plate collar.
I had some Therabands.
So I could put a Theraband around the very
end and then lock them on with collars.
I could kick up, get my feet inside, and then
that allows me to be that one bone, one body
and use my wrists and my shoulders to correct.
As I get fatigued, of course, I’m going
to make mistakes.
I’m going to start correcting by piking
and doing all these bad things that I’ll
get chastised for later by Coach Sommer in
some hilarious emails that I hope to publish
at some point.
Jason Nemer: The Sommer diaries.
Tim Ferriss: The Sommer diaries.
The Notebook, featuring Coach Sommer and Tim
Ferris.
You just tuck down and then you’re out.
It’s just been an incredible accelerator
in terms of getting just mileage in, in that
proper position.
Jason Nemer: This doesn’t surprise me because
in the year plus that I’ve known you, you’ve
asked me so many seemingly gentle questions
that have rocked my world.
And one of them that you asked recently was,
is there a sequence that basically puts together
all of the important poses in AcroYoga?
And I don’t know if you know Bolero?
Tim Ferriss: I don’t.
Jason Nemer: It’s a classical song.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I think I do.
Is Bolero the one that’s played in Ten?
It’s the one that’s played in Ten with
Dudley Moore and Bo Derek.
Jason Nemer: Yes.
And also Caveman, if you’ve seen that movie.
But basically, the guy who wrote that – I
think it’s Ravel – he wrote that to educate
people in all the different pieces of the
orchestra.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, cool!
Jason Nemer: So it starts with violin and
viola, and it’s actually a beautiful song.
But I thought, okay, I have to make this sequence
that basically strings together every pose
that I can think of in AcroYoga.
I want to put Bolero in the background just
as a very educational thing.
It is going to be beautiful.
It’s not about the sequence.
And basically what I’ve done is I’ve made
these grids with front plank, reverse front
plank, back plank, all of these different
things in one column and then all at the top.
And then I cross reference.
What is it like to go from a throne to a reverse
front plank?
Is it beginner, intermediate, advanced, or
an expert or not possible?
So basically what I want to do is go in a
lab, which is with me and a friend, and just
do all these different transitions and then
basically try to get a unified feel of theory
of AcroYoga, basically.
Einstein is one of my heroes and he worked
on this most of the end of his life.
He was trying to see how the strong nuclear
force, the weak nuclear force, gravity, and
electromagnetism were all related.
I feel like something that I want to do with
AcroYoga in my life is to keep pulling out
these equations, pulling out these similarities
between these seemingly unrelated things that
once you crack the code – and this is very
Tim Ferris because you asked the question
– once you crack the code, if I can come
up with a five-minute sequence that has all
of these very important, basic moves.
That’s what unlocks the human potential
for very complicated flying transitions.
Tim Ferriss: It also provides, well, No. 1,
I can’t wait to try it.
No. 2, it also provides motivation for the
student.
And I think that if you look at, for instance
– and this is part of where the thinking
came from because the frustration was born
of – and frustration, I think, in many cases
is a good thing.
It gives you an itch that needs to be scratched
and you need to figure out how to scratch
it.
In this particular case, in any physical practice
that is not regulated in some way by high
stakes competition, which has its own kind
of filtering and self-selection, but it’s
totally different.
Because let’s say you’re in China and
you’re putting together a national gymnastics
team.
You don’t care if you completely destroy
999 athletes to find the one who can tolerate
just an inhuman amount of workload and has
freakish joints.
Jason Nemer: That’s how the Chinese train.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
And it’s also how a lot of military train
dogs, for instance.
They don’t care if 99 of the dogs get completely
messed up as long as they find the one that’s
going to save 100 lives in the field or whatever
it might be.
I shouldn’t say they don’t care but it’s
just an unfortunate common side effect.
But when you’re dealing with recreational
practitioners, and you don’t have, say,
a national championship and that vetting process
and anyone who wants to participate can participate,
I think it’s more akin in some ways to child’s
martial arts.
So how do you keep kids interested in martial
arts?
You have belts.
How do you get the belt?
You have a kata, you have a set form that
at least in theory incorporates all of the
requisite skills that would represent that
level of competence or mastery.
Another analogy would be skiing slopes.
So you have the green circle, the blue square
– I might be getting this wrong – and
then the black diamond, and those are based
on the characteristics of the slope; the steepness,
the terrain features, moguls and so on.
So I was thinking to myself, would it be possible
– and this would also help the business
or the organization of AcroYoga in terms of
retention.
If people want to get to the next belt, i.e.
master the next five-minute sequence, it’s
a mutually beneficial construct because it
keeps the students motivated and it keeps
the entire ecosystem thriving.
I remember thinking to myself, if you look
at whether it’s jiu-jitsu or judo or AcroYoga,
it’s very common.
You go into a class and it’s whatever the
teacher might want to work on that day, or
whatever occurred to them on the drive over;
maybe it’s something they want to practice
themselves.
And there’s a lot of benefit to that.
But at least for an OCD perfectionist idiot
like myself, I need to know where I’m aiming.
Jason Nemer: Where you’re going, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And so the idea of the sequence
was really fun.
That’s what, as you know, I’ve been working
on for the last eight weeks or so.
And ended up getting the entire sequence,
except for one which everybody had trouble
with, even the teachers so I don’t feel
that badly about it; the London spin.
Jason Nemer: Yeah, that one’s hard.
Tim Ferriss: That’s a motherfucker.
But we were able to do it 80 percent of the
time.
But it ain’t pretty.
But the rest of it, it was really fantastic
to have.
This is something that Josh Waitzkin who’s
been on the podcast, so the inspiration for
the book and the movie, Searching for Bobby
Fisher.
Considered a chess prodigy but I don’t think
that applies, even though he has incredible
talents.
He can take his learning system, his approach,
and apply it to just about anything; jiu-jitsu,
his first black belt under Marcelo Garcia
who’s like the Michael Jordan of jiu-jitsu,
ten time world champion, I don’t know.
Just there’s no close second place.
He’s also applied it to a number of other
fields: tai chi, and he’s now applied it
to surfing.
And he would call it learning the macro from
the micro.
Jason Nemer: Oh, I like that a lot.
Tim Ferriss: So for instance, and you can
learn a lot about someone’s body awareness
just by having them do an ATB drill, right?
Jason Nemer: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: If you want to learn, let’s
say, how someone is in language, well, you
could just offer them two pages of dialogue
that include idiomatic jokes, humor.
That’s a high bar.
You can figure out a lot by seeing how they
interact with foreign language humor.
And in Acro, like the corkscrew, that’s
a really good diagnostic tool.
You have to do a lot in the corkscrew.
Jason Nemer: You have to have a lot of proprioceptive
ability and the thing that’s unique with
AcroYoga is you’ve got two people or three
people.
One of my definitions of an advanced practitioner
is somebody who can have success with anybody.
And my first master teacher I ever saw was
a Bulgarian guy named Dema Tarmentoff.
He would literally pick up a 6-year-old kid,
hold him in his hands, chuck him up in the
air and do this thing called a dislocate,
push him to a high hand to hand and hold them
in a one-arm handstand.
I saw this when I was 12, 13 and I was like,
yeah, I want to get that good.
The ability to really support any different
person –
Tim Ferriss: Dislocate sounds terrible.
Is that where you come here and they jump
through the middle?
Jason Nemer: That’s inlocate.
Tim Ferriss: That’s inlocate, okay.
So dislocate is the other way.
Jason Nemer: Dislocate is the other way, where
the arms are here and they go like that.
Tim Ferriss: Oh!
Jason Nemer: Yeah, you’ve got to have some
mobility for that.
Tim Ferriss: I need to work on that.
I’m not ready.
Jason Nemer: You are never doing that.
You can base it; you’re never flying in
it.
I don’t say never that often.
Tim Ferriss: I’m happy to save my shoulders.
They’ve had enough abuse.
Left shoulder already has pins in it; I don’t
need more of those.
I really implore people, and you can find,
I’m sure, a synopsis on this online, but
get a hold of the meta learning section of
the Four-Hour Chef because it talks about
how to work on one skill, to develop it in
such a way that it transfers to many other
skills.
So for instance, if we’re looking at sequencing
and role switching, I think this is really
helpful for any type of partner practice.
In the world of tango, when I was in Argentina,
I learned the female role before I learned
the male role.
Jason Nemer: It’s so much easier to dance.
Tim Ferriss: That seems really weird.
But working with Alicia Monte, who is an incredible
world-class dancer, learning the female role
because we had to; we didn’t have enough
women in the class.
That’s how it came about.
It’s like hey, when Buenos Aries was being
populated by immigrants, the dudes would dance
with one another and it’s like hey, this
isn’t just for the Castro.
There’s actually a functional purpose, here.
After learning the female role, it made it
infinitely easier for me to learn the male
role.
Now in Acro, it’s not a strictly male-female
thing, as we just saw.
But very often, because men are sometimes
or often bigger than the women, they end up
basing.
And they’re just not very flexible, often
times.
You are.
But guys will be like, I have strong legs;
I’ll just hold you on my legs.
Even though I’m kind of chunky by Acro standards,
as a flyer I try to fly whenever possible
when there’s someone like you, or Justin
Bentz, or Daniel Scott or some of these guys
who are just incredibly solid bases.
I want to fly because it helps my ability
to base.
Jason Nemer: Also, one step further than just
understanding, is compassion.
If you’re always basing and you’re saying
to the flyers, why are you so scared?
Then you fly, and you’re like oh, my God,
this shit is scary.
Or vice versa if you’re the flyer and you
base a little bit, you’re like, why are
you so wobbly?
Then you try it and oh, I understand why you’re
wobbly, it’s hard.
Tim Ferriss: In South America there’s this
one woman, very nice, very super flexy flyer,
who was – and I take it that this is a common
term – bossy flyer?
Jason Nemer: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Just like berating the shit out
of every other base.
It was just like okay, why don’t you try
it?
We were doing hand to hands.
It’s like, why don’t you try it?
Why don’t you try to base?
Jason Nemer: That was a humble pie.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, and that remedied the situation
pretty quickly.
And it’s not that one is harder than the
other.
At any respectable level, they both involve
enough complexity and physical demand to be
a humdinger, I think, and very humbling.
For people who are listening or watching,
we’ve talked about the acrobatic flying,
we’ve talked about the therapeutic flying.
The most interesting is not treating those
two as separate practices.
But in the case of, for instance, when I’m
practicing now when I’m doing say 45 minutes
of acrobatic and then 15 minutes therapeutic.
For me, it’s like having two extra days
of recovery.
It was reminiscent, in a way, to what I used
to experience when I was training at this
place called Fairtex here in San Francisco
for Muay Thai.
The Thai trainers would do very rough but
nonetheless therapeutic Thai massage.
Technically they were Thai and they were massaging
me, so I guess it was Thai massage.
But they would walk on you before and after.
That was just part of the warm-up and the
cool-down.
This just reminded me of that self care, what
people might dismiss if they’re kind of
hard edged males especially, as too soft and
new agey or whatever, is actually a performance
enhancer for the hard aspects, in part.
Jason Nemer: For sure.
And this is the term hatha yoga, a lot of
people hear it; it means sun and moon.
Ha is sun, tha is moon.
Tim Ferriss: I didn’t know that.
Jason Nemer: A lot of the physical practice
of yoga is about getting the masculine and
the feminine energy to balance.
So if you are on either side of the spectrum,
we are all on one side of the other unless
we’re super balanced between strength and
flexibility.
Some people naturally are more strong; some
people naturally are more flexible.
Wherever you are as an athlete, as an acrobat,
and even as a yogi, my belief is that you
want to get towards that 50/50.
So somebody like you is not going to expand
their AcroYoga or their yoga practice as intelligently
until you get more mobility.
And so being able to put in these therapeutic
poses at the end of a practice, it’s not
just to make your body feel better in that
moment; it’s to set you up better for your
next practice.
Because if you’re building strength and
you’re not building range of motion, you’re
basically making a time bomb.
And when things go off, then you really need
some deep healing.
So if you do homeopathic doses of healing
along the way, unwinding the tension that
you’ve built up in your practice, it’s
just intelligent training.
Tim Ferriss: The Princess Bride method?
Iocane powder?
Jason Nemer: Exactly.
Did you put it in?
Tim Ferriss: The Dread Pirate Roberts’ training
curriculum.
Jason Nemer: Inconceivable!
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, exactly.
The simplest perhaps incentive that I had
very early on to base, because I was watching
and I’m like, that’s cool.
I think that would be really helpful for jiu-jitsu.
And in fact, there’s a fair amount of crossover,
people who have good kind of rubbery guards
are really effective bases.
And if they want to improve one or the other,
they’re very symbiotic.
Jason Nemer: Right.
Tim Ferriss: But what I realized very quickly
after my first or second attempt, because
I was like, it looks cool, the flying looks
like a little bit more fun but I’m too chunky,
and the basing looks like a lot of work.
But then I did it and what I realized was
when we’re sitting down like this – so
I had developed some back and hip issues – we’re
sitting like this a lot.
And I’m sure Kelly Starrett, PT extraordinaire
could comment on this more intelligently,
but you’re effectively pushing the head
of your femur forward.
You’re sitting down, your femur is getting
set or pressured in an unnatural direction
over extended periods of time.
When I lay on my back, put my legs straight
up in the air and support weight, I’m reseating
the femur in the proper place.
That alone, I feel like just basing someone,
even if it was just basing someone in folded
leaf or bird, which we did – Jack, I’m
flying kind of thing earlier – for a few
minutes at the end of the day is just incredibly
beneficial.
Let me ask some rapid fire questions, the
usual.
When you think of the word successful, who
is the first person who comes to mind, or
people?
Jason Nemer: I’ve got a tie: Gandhi, super
successful, and Einstein; from very different
spectrums of humanity.
They actually met in South America when they
were both alive.
I would have loved to have been the fly on
the wall for that one.
What I see in Einstein that I really appreciate
is he had all the proof he needed to just
keep moving forward with the way that people
understood the world.
And he basically stopped listening to everybody.
He really went inside.
He thought about things, he worked them out,
and he changed the world just from his mind.
The ability to be self reliant, to believe
in yourself and to change the world because
of how brilliant you are and how open your
mind is, that’s a high bar.
I’ve read more about his life and he writes
about love beautifully.
One of my favorite quotes of his, I’m not
going to say it right because it’s in German,
he says, “I like to cut wood because I can
see the fruits of my labor.”
It’s just a lot of really simple things,
because as much as he was in the stars, he
was very pragmatic.
Gandhi, similarly, he didn’t see the world
in the box that he was born into.
When I see people that really don’t take
the world as it’s being presented, and they
have a vision of how things can be and just
that resolve, I feel like both of them were
so committed to their vision and had so much
resolve, and both of them changed the world
in such big ways.
That’s a big definition of success for me.
Tim Ferriss: I want to highlight something
you just said.
Because the ability of Einstein to comment
on beauty, is something that I think – or
to speak on the qualitative aspects of life
with the razor sharp perception of a trained
scientist is something that’s underappreciated,
I think, by people who might be inclined to
be scientists.
It’s very clinical and dry.
Richard Feynman, another great example, physicist
and phenomenal teacher.
Surely You’re Joking, Mr. Feynman! is one
of my favorite books of all time.
Do you have any particular books you’ve
gifted most to other people?
Jason Nemer: The Prophet.
Tim Ferriss: The Prophet.
These are lessons from Jesus?
Jason Nemer: No, he’s a Lebanese guy.
I don’t remember exactly his name, it’s
with a K; first name with a K, last name with
a G. I cannot pronounce it.
Tim Ferriss: That’s alright.
Jason Nemer: He’s this guy who is speaking
to a crowd.
And somebody in the crowd will say, speak
to us of pain.
And he’ll say pain is the blah, blah, blah.
Speak to me of love, speak to me of being
a father.
And I love really – the hairs are standing
up as I think about it – I love really accurate,
condense, Shakti field, energy field statements;
something that you can read in a few minutes
or you can read for your whole life.
So the Tao Te Ching would be a close second,
and I feel like they have similar things where
there’s so much energy in each passage that
you can sit down and speed read it but the
depth of these ideas and these concepts, that’s
actually the book that I have on my traveling
altar because all I do is travel.
So I have the Tao Te Ching and oftentimes
before meditation, I’ll just open it randomly
to a page and read about something and then
just have that be what I steep in as I sit.
Tim Ferriss: I have to ask because you just
reminded me of it.
You are constantly traveling.
You have a very nomadic existence.
Jason Nemer: Not very.
I am fully nomadic.
Tim Ferriss: What belongings do you travel
with?
Jason Nemer: I have a rolling suitcase, a
backpack, and an ukulele.
In the backpack I have my computer, a bunch
of notes that are going to turn into a book
sometime probably this year, and it’s really
dangerous.
Tim Ferriss: Nonfiction?
Jason Nemer: It’s AcroYoga stuff.
I have my altar items in my backpack.
Tim Ferriss: What are in your altar items?
Jason Nemer: Different things from different
places, things that I’ve been gifted from
students.
Tim Ferriss: Like what?
Jason Nemer: Rocks, I got some earrings from
a girl that I’m her godfather.
I’ve got a Mexican flag.
The box is actually from Lebanon because I
was born in Mexico but I have Lebanese heritage.
So it’s just as lot of mementos that remind
me, some photos, as well.
I have a photo of Dharma Mittra, I have a
photo of myself when I was in China competing
at world championships when I was 16.
It’s just things that feel important to
me that keep me grounded.
Tim Ferriss: So in a sense, would you say
– and I don’t want to put words in your
mouth, but I was going to ask, what is the
function of the altar?
But is it your mobile sense of home?
Is that effectively what it is?
Jason Nemer: Yeah.
To a large degree, because of my life and
lifestyle, my home is my community and I have
friends all over the world that if and when
– it’s a when; it’s not an if – when
I stop traveling full-time, I’m going to
not have that part of my life anymore.
So to be able to go to Germany and hang out
with Julie and Pascal and their daughter Leah,
who I love to death and I’ve seen the baby
since she was in the belly and done acrobatics
with them for many, many years; that’s really
what home is.
But having the altar, the unpacking the altar
ritual is just…
When I was a kid, I had Star Wars toys and
games and I would love to set up my Star Wars
stuff.
It’s the same thing, where it’s like this
is my magic kit.
This is what makes me feel like a kid; it
makes me feel excited.
I put a candle on a lot of times when I’m
meditating.
It’s my happy place, my traveling happy
place.
Tim Ferriss: What else do you have?
Jason Nemer: I have some throwing knives.
Tim Ferriss: Throwing knives?
Any particular type of throwing knife?
Jason Nemer: I’ve had many types.
Throwing knives are easy to lose so pretty
much every time I roll through Sacramento,
there’s a place that I know that has them.
That’s where my family is.
Tim Ferriss: Can you mention it?
Jason Nemer: Wild Sports.
Tim Ferriss: Wild Sports throwing knives.
Jason Nemer: Yeah, they’ve got guns, they’ve
got worms and they’ve got throwing knives.
Tim Ferriss: You’re ready for the zombie
apocalypse.
Jason Nemer: You never know.
Tim Ferriss: Have you ever been stopped in
customs for the throwing knives?
Jason Nemer: I haven’t.
The knives were lifted out of my bag in Panama.
Tim Ferriss: Lifted meaning permanently borrowed?
Jason Nemer: Permanently borrowed, yes.
When I was in Bali, I don’t know if you’ve
been; have you been to Bali?
Tim Ferriss: I have, yeah.
Jason Nemer: So you know if you have drugs,
we’re going to kill you?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jason Nemer: Well, another thing on the customs
form is do you have any pointy objects?
And I was like oh, I really don’t want to
give them up.
So I smuggled in some throwing knives to Bali.
I’ve said it out loud.
The Balinese police might hunt me down.
Tim Ferriss: The Balinese Mossad are on their
way.
If so, that’s a huge budget misallocation.
Nemer is not the biggest threat out there.
Anything else that comes to mind?
Jason Nemer: Frisbee.
I am a Frisbee golfer.
Tim Ferriss: I saw a photo of that.
Jason Nemer: I love Frisbee golf.
Basically, I love training in many different
ways, and hand-eye coordination.
Tim Ferriss: Do you have any go-to Frisbee
for Frisbee golf?
I guess it would be disc golf.
Jason Nemer: It’s not a sport, it’s a
pastime.
I correct people when they get really serious
because there are people who have caddies.
Tim Ferriss: What?
Jason Nemer: For real.
Those people think it’s a sport.
It’s a pastime, no matter how hard you work
at it, it’s a piece of plastic and you’re
throwing it around.
I like one called the Rock.
It’s a mid-range disc.
It’s very even flying.
Not super good with distance and the T Bird
is my go-to driver.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
So it really is like having a set of clubs?
Jason Nemer: Yeah, you’ve got your 9 iron,
you’ve got your pitching wedge.
And the discs fly differently.
First of all, you have to get a repeatable
swing before you have any success, just like
golf.
But once you have a repeatable swing, you
can feel the nuance of this one fades left,
this one fades right, this one goes straight.
Tim Ferriss: Is there anything that you’ve
learned in Acro that has translated to helping
the Frisbee golf or vice versa?
Jason Nemer: I think every practice that I
do, they are relatable.
How well I can listen to you with the podcast,
how well I can do any number of things, it’s
all sensitivity, confidence, clarity, repeatability.
So I’m always training and I’m always
playing.
And playing and training, for me, I’ve figured
out a way for them to be synonymous.
So I don’t work hard at things.
I do things that I’m passionate about and
I love what I do.
So everything is related.
Tim Ferriss: This is a funny question, coming
up on your very minimalist kit that you travel
with.
What is the purchase of $100.00 or less that
has had the biggest positive impact on your
life in the last memorable space of time?
Jason Nemer: We’ve already got it.
It’s the Frisbees, for sure.
I was hanging out with my two brothers and
my dad.
We decided to drive up the coast and my two
brothers and me, we’ve played Frisbee golf
our whole lives so we love it, and my dad,
not so much.
But we got a bunch of discs and then we went
really high up on Highway 1 and threw them
out into the ocean.
And my older brother doesn’t like this:
oh, you’re putting plastic in the ocean.
But to watch a disc fly for about a minute,
it’s magical.
In yoga there’s this philosophy, Swaha.
I call it fuck it, whatever; let go.
So when I throw discs – I’ve thrown it
off Machu Picchu, I threw it off Chichen Itza;
they did not like it in Chichen Itza.
But I like to throw Frisbees off of really
high objects.
And when I’m in these very ceremonial places
like Machu Picchu, it’s like what am I releasing?
So it’s an intentional act.
Tim Ferriss: It’s like burning something
on a piece of paper in the flames of a fire.
Jason Nemer: Yeah.
But then you get to watch it fly.
Tim Ferriss: Then you get to watch it fly.
What do you believe that other people think
is insane?
Jason Nemer: That you can trust people.
You can trust a lot of people.
You don’t have to live in fear of strangers.
Strangers are just people you haven’t flown,
yet.
I’ve been all over the world.
My mom was not happy when I was going to go
to the Middle East for the first time.
I was actually in Boston, about to lead a
teacher training and this is when the Boston
Marathon bomber happened.
I had 15 students that were on lockdown for
24 hours.
And I got on the phone to my mom and I’m
like, look, Mom, you think Israel is dangerous,
I’m in Boston.
You cannot hide from danger.
But I don’t think that’s a reason to not
trust people.
I’m a very trusting person.
I’ve traveled the world in some very sketchy
places and I’ve never had anything bad happen
to me.
I assume the best in people.
I assume that I can trust them until they
prove me wrong.
I think a lot of people think that’s crazy.
But when you do this practice enough, trusting
is like a muscle that you flex.
And it doesn’t mean that I’m a cowboy
with it.
Like I have really good credit assessment.
I can tell is this person trustworthy for
this engagement I’m about to have.
But just in general, having an open mind,
having an open heart, believing that people
have good intentions.
Tim Ferriss: How much of that do you think
is bad things not happening to you versus
seeing things in the most positive light?
Because you had your throwing knives lifted
in Panama.
So shit happens, I’m imagining.
Jason Nemer: Well, one of the things that
happened to me that was really amazing was
I had all of my objects liberated from me.
I was living in a van in San Francisco, and
I had my 30th birthday party.
Basically I didn’t want to work in restaurants.
It’s like I’m a yogi, I’m going to do
this; I don’t care how hard it is, I love
this, boom.
So I was living in my van.
My 30th birthday, my friend throws me a party.
That night I got a book on Buddhism, a case
of coconuts, I hung out with my friends.
The next day, my van’s gone.
My home is gone.
Everything is gone.
So I go crack a coconut and start reading
about Buddhism because what the fuck else
am I gonna do?
And page 4 is talking about homelessness and
wandering.
I’m like, that’s what I’m going to do.
And that started my nomadic traveling.
And if I had stayed in San Francisco and tried
to make it as a yoga teacher, AcroYoga wouldn’t
be a worldwide practice.
So the ability to let go of what’s not working
and really assess what is working and what
can I be excited about, it’s true.
It’s not that bad things don’t happen
to me.
I don’t label a lot of things good/bad.
Can I evolve from this?
What do I want now?
Where is my center now?
And this is all from yoga.
Well, not all.
My parents, a lot of other things but yoga
is the daily practice that helps me bring
this wisdom into action steps in my life.
Tim Ferriss: You mentioned something that
I’ve never heard you talk about, and we’ve
never talked about before, but the restaurants
and then the decision, fuck it; I’m gonna
do this full time.
Walk me through the 24 hours that led to that
decision.
At the time, did you realize it was financially
feasible?
Or was it just a Hail Mary, this is what I’m
meant to do?
Walk me through the 24 hours before you’re
like, alright, I’m pulling the trigger;
this is what I’m doing.
Jason Nemer: I made up my resume for restaurants,
and I was living in San Francisco.
We had a rent-controlled house that three
yogis were living in because the people that
had the rent control left town.
I was dirt bagging it, but at that point,
all I needed was yoga and food.
I didn’t need money.
I didn’t have other ambitions.
I wasn’t traveling the world.
So if I had enough money to take yoga classes
and to eat well, that’s all I needed.
When I got to that point of do I get a job,
or do I really dedicate to the yoga thing,
it really wasn’t a choice.
It was such a big thing that happened in my
life when yoga really hit me over the head;
this is all I want to do and if I do these
other things, I’m not being true to the
practices that I’ve been learning about.
Like this is time for me to really dedicate
to this.
My mom had a van, and she didn’t need it.
I never thought I would live in a van but
San Francisco was, and still is, super competitive
with yoga.
Yoga teachers are some of the most underpaid
people on the planet because they have the
potential to really bring a lot of beauty
to people’s lives, and they get paid $30
to $100 a class, depending on what city you’re
in.
So if I didn’t live in the van, there really
weren’t a lot of other solutions I saw,
until the van was liberated and then I saw
the other solutions.
Living on the road, you’re never really
successful, at least I haven’t been, in
the cities where you start things.
You go further away from where things started
and you’re more luxurious and more exotic.
San Francisco is still a difficult city to
fill a room for me.
So if I would have kept hitting my head against
that wall, I wouldn’t be here, the practice
wouldn’t be here.
Tim Ferriss: I love it.
I love that.
We’re going to wrap up with just a few last
questions.
I suppose this is as good a place as any to
ask if you had a billboard and could put anything
on it, what would you put on it?
Jason Nemer: Play!
Play more.
Play.
Yeah.
I feel like people are so serious.
And it doesn’t take much for people to drop
back into the wisdom of a childlike playfulness.
I think if I had to prescribe two things to
improve health and happiness in the world,
it’s movement and play, those two things.
Because you can’t really play without moving
so they’re kind of intertwined.
But if you’re just moving and you’re not
enjoying yourself as you’re moving.
If you’re on a treadmill, treadmills kill
your spirit.
There are reasons and times to do treadmills,
but if that is your only way of moving your
body, you’re selling yourself short.
There are way cooler ways to move your body;
way more fun things and I just happened to
have the good fortune to learn a lot of these
really cool things.
So play.
Tim Ferriss: Awesome.
Jason, where can people find you online?
What would you like them to check out?
Jason Nemer: Acroyoga.org is the website and
there are free learning opportunities.
AcroYoga International is the name of the
company that I run.
And on YouTube, you can go there and see a
bunch of free videos that get you started.
Tim Ferriss: What is the handle on YouTube?
Jason Nemer: AcroYoga International.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, AcroYoga International.
And we’ll put all this in the show notes,
folks so you can find everything else.
Anything on social you’d like to mention;
Instagram, Twitter, Facebook?
Where are you?
Jason Nemer: It’s all AcroYoga and it’s
all Jason Nemer.
So JasonNemer.com, JasonNemer on Instagram.
I try to keep it simple because I like to
keep things simple if I can.
Tim Ferriss: Awesome, man.
So much fun.
Always great to hang.
Jason Nemer: Right on.
Tim Ferriss: More flying and basing in the
future.
Jason Nemer: What a weird grip.
That’s not very useful.
There we go.
Good stuff.
Thank you, Tim.
Tim Ferriss: Thanks.
Everybody listening and everybody watching,
as always, you can find the show notes at
fourhourworkweek.com/podcast.
I’ll have links to everything that we talked
about.
And until next time, thank you for listening
and thank you for watching.
Signing off.
Jason Nemer: Ya, mon.
Tim Ferriss: Ya, mon.
Jason Nemer: That was fun.